I'm gonna show you how to do with this
which you can bring in 22 okay now this
is the second way which is with now if
you stare really hard at the buttons on
your calculator and the small characters
that are labeling above and below I
wonder if you can see something that
might be useful to you that will do
something similar to this now depending
on your calculator if you look at the
decimal point my decimal point looks
like this okay how many of you hands up
have exactly that 13 yet heads up
okay thank you yes now how many of you
have it so it looks like that just the
left hand one yeah okay sure so what I'm
gonna do for the purposes of this
demonstration I'm just gonna pretend you
have this calculator if you have a
slightly different one I can show you
what to do with that instead but what we
want is this one on the right hand side
the difference between these is to do
this will give you a random number
between 0 and 1 this will give you a
random whole number an integer between
just like this any two numbers you
choose okay so I'm gonna go with this
one on the right hand side and if you
have something slightly different I'll
show you how to work with that so on
mine um these two this is in yellow and
this is in like pink fuchsia whatever it
is okay so I have to press alpha to get
to this on my display okay so if I push
alpha decimal point okay now on my
screen it says this okay and then it
bracket opens up now this works exactly
the same way that the spreadsheet does
right it just doesn't tell you so you
need to put in a pair of numbers between
whatever and whatever like say 1 and 24
go ahead and do that you might say
where's the coma never used no
my my cover is above my right bracket so
if you've got the up the right brackets
I've got a comma and X above that it's a
press shift comma and then 24 don't
forget to close the bracket so you can
see the more times you press equals the
more numbers you'll get and it keeps
like handing you random numbers so
that's all fine okay I guess you take
the first the first four okay or first
five I said that's what I wanted
so you can use the spreadsheet you can
use a calculator there's one last way
that I want to show you it has to do
with this piece of paper
okay so spreadsheet calculator option
three creative numbers so if for
instance you find yourself out in the
desert and you have no technology then
you have access to write if you have
something as simple as a grid of novels
you can use one of these to get out your
random sample okay so let me show you
how to do this I need to turn this back
on whoops okay right around numbers the
same yeah okay cool more or less all
right so that's the one I wanted now
that'll do what I'm gonna show you is
and can I sort of emphasize right these
are supposed to be random numbers okay
so in a way it doesn't matter how you
generate these so long as they are
really random and so that's why I'm show
you all these different ways now this
last one I kind of think is the weirdest
of the lot but it's one that's in your
text so I don't want you to look at that
thing what on earth am I supposed to do
with that I want you to know okay so
it's not complicated all you need to do
is two things number one pick a starting
point a starting point
for the sake of consistency so you can
come back to your notes later and be uh
okay that's what it means let's all pick
the same starting point I'm gonna go to
the third column of numbers the third
column of numbers this one I'm gonna go
down to the fifth row and that first
number there it's a nine okay so I'm
gonna just treat that as my start number
and then all I need to do from there to
get my random series of numbers is I
want numbers from 1 to 24 right so I
need to pick a pair of digits every time
a pair of digits every time so here's
what I'm gonna do I'm just gonna walk
down the page like this okay now you can
see and I'm gonna put some arrows maybe
you want to do this on your piece of
paper too as you walk down the page
you're getting a series of random
numbers out of this walk right now I
want to digit numbers unfortunately
because of the spot that I picked
actually maybe I'll just go up one this
is really cheap there we go okay it
actually doesn't matter where I start I
still end up with a problem I want you
to see what two digit numbers I gathered
this okay so if we started like the at
the nine like I originally said my first
number is 95 see that this there's the
first two and then I've got 82 83 when I
get to this six down the bottom I guess
I'd need to go up to the next the next
column some be 67 then 50 and so on okay
so you can see I'm gonna get 67 I went
up to the next column
67 yeah I'm just a Z and I'm going
through all of the columns left to right
that makes sense okay now you can see
for this particular example our base
numbers not bad uses to me unfortunately
because if I want numbers from 1 to 24
there's only well there's only about a
24 percent chance that I'm gonna get
another that's more okay you can see all
these numbers are quite large they're
all over 24 so I can't use any new
things but if I was if I had a group of
a hundred people then I'd pick the 95th
person at the 82nd 83
67 I will still get a random sample of
some kind just that makes sense no
there's no reason why I had to walk down
let's start somewhere else for instance
let's go over here that's good at this
one which starts with them which ends
with a 7 see that one over there on the
right-hand column what I can do here if
I want to digit numbers right I can say
all right I'm going to go to the left
why don't go to the left okay so the
first number I'm gonna get will be 74
and then I'll go to the left the next
one just so it's a bit easier for you to
read I'll use a different color the next
one will be 62 can you see that the next
one will be 73 the next one will be 66
and as I move towards the left I keep on
getting a new set of numbers here nice
didn't we yeah so I'm just gonna write
them down just so you see how I did this
74-62 7366 dot dot dot so you can see
there's more ways than you can shake a
stick at to get random numbers out of
this I didn't have to do it going from
right to left I could have made that 47
26:37 the important thing is I described
how I'm getting these numbers and
they're not just coming in and by here
okay they're coming out of something
random and that's what will give me a
random sample does that make sense